[Music]
yes
man
[Music]
celebrate
it's Monday weekend is over another
batch of beautiful hell headed right up
your face or but actually probably I'm
just thinking face I don't know why I
said but man I'm just I'm just being
kooky I'm being kooky I'm being kooky
what the [ __ ] i I guess I'm not
I mean kooky what am i if I'm being cool
you know like hood there's no you're not
cool no cool guys being kooky you know
some just whatever I'm whatever I'm the
same thing you are and whatever good to
be here with you guys today it is Monday
September 18th and welcome to this past
weekend the Emmys are on if you got to
watch the Emmys I think for some people
is probably a nice respite for people
that have really been struggling and you
know stuck in the storms and had their
you know their homes ravaged and lost a
lot I bet it was actually kind of nice
for some people to relax and just you
know have their their mind taken away by
by the award show I didn't watch
I don't really to me it's it does seem a
bit much to see you know a bunch of
well-to-do people
rewarding themselves or awarding
themselves I feel like we're at a time
when there are kind of bigger heroes in
the world and in America than people who
are good at acting are good at
pretending I feel like we're in a time
where we you know we're I don't we're in
a time what the [ __ ] am I even saying
but I feel like I'd rather see people
being real you know I'd rather see
awards for people being real than people
pretending because it seems like it's
harder and harder to find realness these
days to find something that kind of that
feels authentic that feels like it's not
produced
and that's why I don't I just don't need
don't need the Emmys this year for me
you know I do miss some of those old
days of those crazy awards shows though
and maybe I need to get back into him
but no Emmys for me right now I feel
like I'd rather watch something else I
just got back from Cleveland and they're
baseball team had won 21 straight games
when I rolled into town the Cleveland
Indians named after I'm guessing Native
Americans and while I was there they
lost so sorry Cleveland but I had a good
time I had a great time there actually
spent some just just quality time with
some locals dude saw somebody get maced
it was started like a fun thing a couple
of kind of thicker girls and I think the
mace was like kind of that rapey that
you know that rape prevention mace that
you know that rpm if you will and then
you know these [ __ ] got wild you know
these [ __ ] got a little bit British
on each other and they started you know
kind of attacking each other one of them
had like a shawl it was some special
event I think you know I don't know if
it was a wedding or somebody had like a
fifth child or something I don't know
what you know when you get the shawl if
it's a parenting thing as well as a
marriage bachelorette thing but [ __ ] got
crispy and then [ __ ] started macing
each other and I don't use the term
[ __ ] towards all women but in the
beginning there were ladies and by the
end you know they were I mean they were
out there on cobblestones barefoot
rolling around a lot of dirty sequins in
the streets you know not athletes either
I'm gonna go ahead and classify these
ladies as not athletes but that was part
of Cleveland man there was a lot more
had some good times there eat some good
corned beef
shout out to my buddy Tom McRobbie he
came through we lost a limb last year so
it was good to see him last time I saw
me had two limbs and this time one limb
and arms I mean he had other two limbs
legs and he still has those
so it's interesting when you said when
you have a friend who goes down a limb
because you kind of as a person who
still has all their limbs I have I got
everything right now you kind of don't
know how to approach it so you show up
sort of you know like especially if it's
an arm it's like do a hug do I you know
touch him on the neck like what do I do
you know you know what do I do but it
was pretty beautiful man he had had an
amputation and then he got part of his
he got the limb burned up because some
people think you can only get cremated
if you're dead but not true if you lose
a limb you can also get the limb
cremated and it was pretty beautiful
that he had a a keychain with like one
of those little I don't feel like a
corona bottle you get it to be like a UH
like a if you go down a Destin Florida
you know um Punta Cana Yaya or somewhere
one of those beach towns and you can get
those little things with the sand in
them those Corona bottles but he had
that with a little bit of his what
originally was his other appendage so
that was you know his new is kind of
novel I guess and it was I think him
making the most out of being you know
down to one slapstick you know and
that's where he's at so good to see him
man good to see him what else happened
in Cleveland it was I stayed at this
beautiful hotel called the arcade I
worked at hilarities we had saw some
ginormous tits met a dude who was kind
of crippled a little bit had the worst
breath you know what I'm saying here's
what I'm saying if you're gonna be
crippled brush your teeth that's one of
my things right because here's the thing
we all are crippled in some way right so
I guess this goes for all of us we got
to take care of what we have left and
that's what I think maybe is gonna be
some of the theme today is this taking
care of what we have left you know
you're down a limb brush your [ __ ]
teeth man you're down on you got spina
bifida wash behind your ears you know
I've got mental health disorders and
certain sentimental health disorders and
you know uh you know my dick gets a
little bit queasy sometimes when I'm
trying to do sex you know
then that means I got to make sure that
I comb my hair and wash it you know it's
like we got to take care of what we have
left you know we got to covet those
things and that goes back to my boy
Tommy Mac who's sure he has only got one
arm but but if that other arm is always
with him you know and he's taking a
little bit of piece of that in a
commercialized kind of Corona bottle I
wish that the corona thing wasn't on
there and if he's listening to this
maybe you you know file that off of the
bottle I think it's a little bit cooler
if it doesn't seem like you know my old
arm is brought to you by you know a
Mexican beer anyhow I'm happy to have
you guys and I want to thank everybody
in Cleveland that came out my buddy
Kevin best who makes all my shirts he
makes all of the Hampshire --tz-- and
some new shirts we got a new shirt
that's coming out that's going to have
all the tour dates on it that'll be
online soon and he and he and his whole
family came through and just always a
pleasure to see them and his brother
actually lives in his basement and makes
the shirts so his brother you know
enjoys a good bit of whiskey and
different zippers and he lives down in
his basement and that man makes the
shirt so you know if you're getting a
shirt from me that that shirt is made by
the hands of a man who's living in a
basement running off alcohol and there's
something old-fashioned about that and
there's something beautiful about that
while I was in Cleveland also went over
to Akron and people know that you know
I'm a sober guy and I went to this guy
dr. Bob's house and dr. Bob is was
incremental in the starting of
Alcoholics Anonymous and he and his wife
almost ran this sort of halfway house
where they helped I mean tons of people
get sober and get their life on track
and they the the house is like a
National Monument now so it's just I
mean it was really touching for me to go
in there in this lady I won't say her
name because you're not supposed to say
people's names but she is just a
volunteer there and she just kind of
shares her story with you and she shows
you all around this guy's house where he
was hiding
dr. Bob and it was just incredible I
mean that was just an incredible time
for me to be just to be in that
environment it just really inspired me
to kind of stay on the path that I'm on
at the moment with you know staying off
that liquor and staying off of that
cocaine maybe that dust you know because
people's out there on it and if you're
struggling out there and if you get a
chance to go to Akron to get to just
feel that just that I mean it's just a
beautiful it's just a beautiful fire
that's it's just it's not even a real
fire but it's just the air is just
burning with just this energy that's I
mean it just it just lifts your [ __ ]
makes your feet grow I mean you just
feel like you're standing this the
foundation of something special is right
there beneath your feet
so that was really amazing to be a part
of and to get to see that and I also
have an announcement that we have a
sidekick in studio today he's going to
be doing a residency with this here for
a while and I appreciate him being here
my man ari Manus is here thanks for
having me Theo this is very exciting
yeah thank you so much man I'm big fan
of Ari and his comedy he's a comedian
how long you been doing it almost five
years now yeah yeah religiously yeah I
don't think I've taken a week off really
how you feel too guilty to in my head
about it
what's the longest you ever take it off
I guess a week yeah I don't know if it's
an addiction sometimes to keep doing it
at this point it's the job you know yeah
and you won't be able to see Ari on the
youtubes you'll be able to see him next
week today we're not gonna show his
beautiful mugs yeah I don't feel
comfortable I've been gone for the
weekend I feel a little sunburned yeah
there's a little self-conscious about
I've body image issues that's fine I'll
be ready next week what get you about
your body like when you think about body
image issues like I'm not fat
right but I don't want take my shirt off
either yeah you know if we went to the
the beach with some ladies yeah I
probably just leave my shirt on and sit
by the towel gbesi and you're the lean
guy with his shirt on at the beach yeah
that's an interesting I got I got some
moles yeah yeah you have any moles body
moles you know I've been pretty
fortunate to
not have a lot of those body moles yeah
I've got a few of them removed from when
I was a kid my parents would take me to
dermatologists and get them surgically
removed but now I can't really afford to
go there myself I could probably afford
it I just you know I have other
priorities where I want to put my money
into besides getting mold removed yeah I
just let him let him go well some people
it almost seemed like you see some
people out there were some really big
moles or groups of moles you know you
see some people with some damn you know
I met a girl one time had practically
the Little Dipper on her back you know
and you see people with these sequences
of moles and you wonder what the waddle
they don't want to remove them but I
guess it's part of you you know and some
people believe in ancient cultures that
you carry different parts of your spirit
in these little pockets of your body in
a mold yeah yeah it's part of me yeah
sure but maybe one day so I could
imagine that now if they get too big
they say if they get bigger than a dime
you got to cut them off and one time I
got spent some time around an escort and
she had a leaping from no it was a sort
of a it was kind of an arrangement but I
didn't get involved with the escort but
she had a mole that was oh man it was
Mount Rushmore I mean this thing was
huge dude this thing was a dam I mean in
another life it had had a grandiose life
you know you think she had some clients
that maybe paid a little extra to be
with that birthmark I could see some I
could see people being into that maybe
maybe some Asian guys or Japanese
business man yeah but I don't know that
and it was heating up it was almost like
a but it was like it kind of had the red
around the base and stuff I mean it gets
very alarming you know and it's almost
like when you see a sick tree sometime
you'll see a sick tree and its roots
have like this kind of white on them or
the you know it'll be kind of splotchy
around the bottom and you know that that
tree's sick and that's kind of what was
going on with her and I remember I gave
her $150 and the the information to a
one of my good friends who is a
dermatologist and and sent her in his
direction I know she got it removed but
but hopefully yeah yeah but how was your
weekend man let's get into sit let's get
in a little bit of your weekend my
weekend was intense you know there was
the ups and the downs I was in the big
pine comedy festival in Flagstaff
Arizona yes beautiful contrast Mountain
Country up there and they actually a
good Mexican food up there yeah they do
it's interesting like you think of
Arizona or at least I think of Arizona
and I think just this desert desolation
but a Flagstaff is a Foresti there's
pine trees everywhere it's a little
cooler than the rest it's a little more
hip it's a college town and it's yeah
it's beautiful it's awesome
it got to do some stand-up at some bar
shows nice for some small audience I won
best of fest oh really which means I get
to perform for a paid week at the house
of comedy in Arizona that'll be exciting
I'm my second graduate thank you thank
you very exciting just working my way up
one little festival at a time but you
know then there was also some intense
moments in the weekend I went to the
Grand Canyon cuz there's only about an
hour and a half from the Grand Canyon
I've never been there oh nice yeah I
never been there either so I was
thinking I gotta go I'm here I'm this
close and when you're getting up to the
Grand Canyon are you do you have
expectations do you feel like it was
gonna be not as good as you had heard
like what were some of your thoughts
when you go up to a national thing like
that because I remember when I went to
Mount Rushmore I was like artists things
gonna be a piece of [ __ ] you know but
when I got to Mount Rushmore and I think
it's in North Dakota or South Dakota it
blew my mind it was really really
awesome and they had they had built so
much stuff around it like going up to it
that the most of the because the faces
are just up there in the mountain but
there's all this structure and this
cement and marble going up to it that
you're just it almost inch
you're almost tranced before you get
there what was it like at the canyon so
I'd only seen pictures I've occurred but
you know all the lake hills locals are
saying you got to go it's incredible so
I had high expectations and I'm going
there with my girlfriend - I should
mention I brought my girlfriend the
festival right and I'll mention I know
this that you have a live-in girlfriend
yeah she moved in three weeks into the
relationship and I'm
ever lived with a girl before Wow and
again I'll say there's a you know the
ups and downs to having a girlfriend and
a living girlfriend but so so she's
coming with me for this journey to
Flagstaff and how long have you guys
been seeing each other
so good while and I know in the
beginning you were talking a lot about
different sex and different sexual
activities whenever you and I was to
each other the comedy story you were
telling me some of these you know just
that it was exciting there's a lot of
yeah I mean we're I'm very attracted to
her so in the beginning we were probably
having three sessions daily three sexual
sessions that it felt like a teenager
you know yeah that's children like an 18
year old young buck just explore in the
world I didn't how you haven't done that
since I'll probably 15 years 16 years
old you know really been involved in one
maybe 1718 yeah I lost my virginity at
17 yeah me too actually
so so it would have been around there
that I was really wanting to do sex more
than once a time you know because after
I sometimes I like these days I have a
lot of anxiety I'll hold my breath
during sex I had this thing for a while
I would hold my breath during sex and
just get going and then I would almost
kind of pass out that sounds exciting
yeah it wasn't and it wasn't like part
of one of those you know you hear a lot
of these Asian culture tricks where
people are you know tying themselves up
to pipes and [ __ ] in the closet and all
that you know we're trying to you know
handcuff in their feet to their neck and
all this kind of [ __ ] to get you know
higher climax ratio or whatever you know
spraying out heavily and that never I
wasn't trying to do that I would just be
like I was just so much weird anxiety
and stuff that I would just find myself
holding my breath during sex and then
just you know kind of come to that's
interesting yeah ours is more normal
yeah as far as I know she's not holding
my breath I was just breathing I wasn't
even thinking about my breath I'll just
breathing regular and yeah so we're it
weren't Flagstaff together we're heading
to the Grand Canyon and then on our way
there we start fighting because she
bought this new lamp for our apartment
and she didn't tell me about it she just
surprised me with this new lamp with a
layup surprise and I'm just kind of like
can we just talk about make these issues
decisions together you know kind of a
dumb fight but a common one with us
you know just not not taking me into
consideration that's how I fell Oh a
common with couples to my buddy uh
vard this dude I used to know name VAR
he was from I don't know another country
sounds kind of Russian maybe yeah I
think it was somewhere over there
Ukraine and he had money one time him
and his wife he save up some money to
get a new carpeting and he spent all the
money on drugs and uh and he ended up
just he got literally got cardboard but
thick cardboard nailed down in their
entire apartment we had cardboard put
into their apartment it sounds like he
did the drugs then decided the cardboard
yeah the car burst her it was tertiary
to those like a drug based decision oh
yeah it could have been part of it but I
mean he had it professionally done so
we've had you know like commercial grade
never seen that yeah throughout his
entire place that actually sounds kind
of different like you're kind of selling
that like I want to see that yeah yeah
well look man flooring his big man I
remember growing up and that was a big
thing around Louisiana was people did
flooring you know a lot of people that
you know did drugs and couldn't find a
lot of work we'd get into flooring and
they had people they'll put [ __ ]
flooring on your ceiling you know they
had people that was a big thing you know
if you ever had flooring on your ceiling
and people were getting linoleum
ceilings done and they had some
interesting stuff going on so okay so
she got the lamp so we're in this dumb
fight on the way to the Grand Canyon and
we ended up breaking up on the way to
the Grand Canyon so she's now telling me
I don't want to go to Grand Canyon with
my ex-boyfriend you broke up with me
take me back to Flagstaff and I and I'm
thinking this is my one chance to see
the Grand Canyon it's what I had been
planning for weeks I'm going to the
Grand Canyon yeah well you there maybe
so I'm an hour away at this point yeah
so I ended up forcing this girl that I
just broke up with to go with me to the
Grand Canyon's so we're there she's
crying calling me a sociopath saying
that I shouldn't have taken a I
shouldn't force her to go the Grand
Canyon
liam neeson show up in this I feel like
this is like uh trafficking go on and so
I'm just trying to enjoy it by the way
it was an incredible I think I would
have enjoyed it more had I not been in
this conflict yeah lady
oh I'm sure what was it hard to like
because yeah if you want to get pictures
done or something you can't I took no
pictures and I think if I that's
definitely something I would have taken
pictures yeah if I hadn't been in that
fight mindset so I just you know I
soaked it in and probably only stayed
about 15 minutes also because of it and
did you go in that glass floor they have
that glass drawbridge no what I found
out is that I thought about that that's
about $80 and it's not at the main Grand
Canyon place because the Grand Canyon I
didn't realize how big it was it looks
big in the photos but the Grand Canyon
is humongous it's huge its vast you
can't you can't see it all on it
somebody tried to jump it didn't they
maybe there was like a narrow part that
Evel Knievel or something that up jump
the Grand Canyon so you got so it would
not as she enjoy the Grand Canyon at all
no she was crying and she kept saying
take let's leave I don't want to be here
let's leave so oh you know enjoy it as
much as I could mm-hmm and then and then
we left and then we went back and then
we had this awkward and you drove back
yeah we drove back to LA so we had this
awkward eight hour broken up car ride
y'all stayed there last night no we we
left after my show so we left there
about 10:00 p.m. and drove into the
night into this fresh breakup right and
she's crying I'm playing music as long
as I can to drive makes me sound very
intense I I'm not trying to be
insensitive you being a man I'm just
trying to to move on as best as I can we
were just you know music was it probably
Akai probably wasn't that pot wasn't the
best choice music emo stuff like human
ears or chainsmokers all of that yeah so
it's similar genre that for sure
so she's crying we're broken up and let
me also say you know we broke up just
because we're fighting too much yeah
that's what
came down to it wasn't I didn't cheat on
her she didn't cheat on me there wasn't
any heartbreak so to speak this has been
happening this has been happening been
living so then we get home yeah because
we live together still mmm and we end up
having seven sex know how did you know
that I mean I just I guess I just hoped
it day yeah we and it sounds like one of
the best and worse like porn videos you
can ever watch it's like a couple goes
to the Grand Canyon there's crying
there's the long car ride I think more
porn videos should be like this because
it ain't real it would be real and you
get some reality along with this porn
because a lot of this porn there it's
there's no real reason why these people
are [ __ ] most of the time no and half
of them there's not like actually I me I
found out actually on your other podcast
also Keira remember that oh yeah she
called me a unicorn because I like porno
with storyline to add a little bit more
realism to it because at most these
pornos now they're just dressed up in
fishnets so and they just go to town
right away oh yeah it's just Dirk well
it's just people just just paint hunters
out there these people hunt hunting the
John and hunting booty holes out there
exactly sometimes they'll leave these
booty holes open or if you've ever seen
any this gave action oh oh man and it's
just and I worry that these women are
gonna catch cold or they're gonna it
just seems so unprofessional
you know I think the cold is probably
the least of their worries yeah I'm
worried about more permanent like what
if that gaping never goes away oh yeah
let's do name without it too heavy so we
end up having sex and in my mind I'm
thinking this is breakup sex right but
in her mind it was makeup sex we're back
together
Wow so now we're back together really
yeah so right now you guys are together
yeah so I have a girlfriend again what
do I do you know I think I'm just gonna
roll with it yeah I mean do you still do
you still care about her yeah I do I
care about I'm just I'm just I kind of
trying to be drama-free in my life and
every time we get in all these fights
and I'm just like I don't need that
I don't need this drama in my life I
don't need these fights but do you think
you're looking for the fear look you're
you're also in your head no matter what
as it headed towards a place of ending
because that's one thing sometimes you
that you it's like weird when you
already know the outcome but you're
still playing with we already know the
answer but you're still playing with the
numbers you know I think I'm gonna I'm
gonna keep it open-minded I don't I'm
not gonna say that it's over or we're
gonna be together forever I'm just kind
of long for the ride along for the ride
Wow Grand Canyon that's crazy Joe Dirt
did I remember when I first saw Joe Dirt
I thought it was a documentary and when
I finally got to meet David Spade I
remember talking to him and saying you
know we did a lot of people reach out to
you and you know a lot of orphans reach
out to you about your journey and he's
like what in the [ __ ] any literally
thought I was one of the dumbest you've
ever met but uh whatever you know I'm on
your side I would think like kids
especially yeah and orphans most of them
this is something I'm just guessing here
but I'm guessing most want that educated
compared to the non orphans so they're
probably watching this movie and no
one's there to tell him it's a fake
thing I'm on your side I would assume
that orphans would have reached out to
him yeah there was no back when that
movie came out there was no Facebook and
Twitter really wasn't not you couldn't
get those extracurricular so a lot of
people I'm sure were you know who had
been in between homes or just left
somewhere you know it I'm sure it
resonated with them that way and that's
all I was I mean I guess it just hit me
like that it just seemed like a you know
an orphan that had you know and gotten
left at the Grand Canyon and found his
way ya know
well we'll get into some calls man
that's a good question like what do you
do what do you do with that relationship
I mean I you know it's been so long
stuff in a relationship I don't even
remember what those fights are like I
mean I just remember the sex was good
when I was young you know like sober sex
I feel like it's for children you know
when I was when I was young when you're
young you can [ __ ] you just everything's
so exciting you know somebody's leg or
hip or you know just you know seeing
your own nuts
I can hear all that [ __ ] is just just
exciting dude it's like watching the
damn nature Channel yeah you know and
even seeing a piece of ass or a you know
a titty fly out of something but just
you know or feeling some titty and like
you know putting two of your fingers in
somebody's mouth at the same time or
just being nasty it just you it's all so
natural and then you get older and
you're just like ah jeepers you know the
last thing you want to do is [ __ ]
something you really know that sounds I
feel bad for you yeah maybe yeah you
know what
may I mean I don't know I'll be seeing
my therapist tomorrow at 9 a.m. dance so
you know where I'll be yet but we got
some great calls Ari and I'm gonna come
here I'm gonna have you yeah I'm gonna
have you stick with us on these calls
and thank you for being here yeah we're
gonna have our Ian for next week he'll
be on video you can catch them on
YouTube as well and we're gonna just
keep it cruising I got some dates I'm
gonna drop it's just Huntsville November
16th through 19th huntsville alabama and
be my first time performing in the state
of alabama so pretty stoked and i know
that you will be november 3rd and 4th at
the la jolla comedy yeah excited for
that so people can check that out
something pretty funny this weekend
Donald Trump president Donald Trump
tweeted he made a reference to Kim Jong
yeah
yang hmm kim jeong-hoon then could be
Kim Jong Kim Jong yeah he called him a
Rocket Man which I thought was pretty
funny I thought that was pretty
interesting and I'm also I've done a
little bit more research into getting my
you know it's no secret that I wish my
neck was a little bit longer and I don't
know if you have things about yourself
that you don't like oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah and one of mine is I wish I always
wish out a little bit more neck you know
my arms are only kind of medium length
arms and people can maybe see him on the
YouTube and just medium length arms yeah
medium and but I was wanting arms were a
little bit more reach II you know you
know just really yeah so you could get
something so you could hug a
[ __ ] and they knew who you were
you don't want to be able to hug
somebody and just tickle them at the
same time you know and then you also
want along her neck but I've always
wanted a little bit longer neck so I
have invested in a few neck
races I was gonna say what are the
things that the Africa and women the
stretches is that too extreme for you or
would you be willing to experiment with
something like that well I would
experience neck braces and adult neck
braces and I'm going to start with the
child's and wear it in the evenings and
see if it starts to just give me a
little bit of length now I am I'm also
making sure that I don't detach anything
or damage myself but I'm excited to have
just a little bit more another
suggestion I have this is kind of more
long-term thought yeah but probably stay
away from neck exercises you know
because muscle will only make it look
kind of girthier and shorter so you
probably want a thin neck yeah so I'd
stay away from any kind of exercise or
sport that uses a lot of neck muscles
yeah yeah and you know and I've quit
lifting the weights you know which has
been interesting and got more than a
stretch and and doing yoga actually and
doing things a little bit more
beneficial to my soul them out and
getting my reaching going and it is nice
you do feel a little bit more in control
to your body which I like but I want to
have you know I want to have a
turtleneck and and not look like I'm
trying to hide from people you know I
want to have that reach I want people to
look at me like oh that guy can look
around I'm excited to see what happens
with the neck braces we'll see but I
will say from just from an outsider's
perspective just from me your friend
known you for a few years I've never
thought to myself Theo has a limited
limited neck I've never thought that
about you to me your necks pretty fine
so I wouldn't worry about it too much
regardless of if the neck brace works or
not
alright yeah appreciate that appreciate
that but yeah I'm gonna try it and I
guess I'll keep you guys posted let's
get into some calls the hotline is nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three we're going to get into some calls
right now and if you want to hit that
hotline with any thoughts responses
anything you can let us know what you
what you think of having a sidekick on
I'm interested in everybody's thoughts
and feelings so are you really under the
microsites a yeah can you be if you're
gonna leave thoughts about me just be
sensitive that I'm a person yeah
I have feelings yeah hundred percent
brother alright let's get into some
calls right here alright let's get into
some calls right here hey Theo this is
Dylan green I'm from Bellingham
Washington we have in the top left
corner of the nation love the show man I
think what you're doing is awesome
Bellingham Washington Oh Washington has
clean water country you know a lot of
Native Americans went up there to get
clean water and they stayed there let's
keep it going and all the power to keep
doing it never stop thanks to mom a
little story for ya and husband talked
about it
just want to share this one with you I
when I was in eighth grade my my class
went on the science trip to California
and that was pretty exciting for us all
and I was dating what was my first
girlfriend then and this is where I had
my my first in the pants experience with
a young lady which is pretty radical
yeah
man and you know what I feel I feel is
it perverted of me to think about those
times in my life sometimes no that's
normal everyone does that because it's
weird if I'm thinking about you know I
remember making love to my girlfriend on
the trip to Walt Disney World's and we
went there and they had a bus and we
ended up just doing sex in the seat at
night what everybody else is resting and
but when I think about that now those
are children having sex in my head you
know even though I'm one of the children
it just I don't know I just have some
something about it feels a little like
too much you know that's a you were a
young adult 17 young adult yeah young
adult okay let's hear the rest of your
story brother and it was crazy were just
sitting on this bus and we were driving
from one Science Museum to the other and
there was parent chaperones surrounding
us yeah nothing feels better do than
getting a little bit of trim when they
got some parental chaperones around you
know it's like when there's mice running
around and you're holding a [ __ ]
warm chunk of cheese in your hand and
none of them no brother that is truly
beautiful praise God let's go some more
and we just got down and dirty right in
that bus and it was awesome and that
thinking looking back though it's pretty
odd to think that you know 13-year old
my 13 year old self was kind of getting
into that action and my question to you
is like what are your thoughts on you
know I'm when kids start experimenting
with that kind of [ __ ] I'm 25 year old
young man now and thinking about like my
13 year old cousin getting into that
sort of stuff blows my mind well that's
a great question
like it's we it's interesting cuz it's
like for us it was whatever happened was
okay you know as long as it was like two
consenting young people and you were
just like learning and riding your
hormones and you know feeling those
young crotch nuptials and stuff like
that yeah it was normal but when you
think about like your own child at 13
you know doing that or like he's saying
his nephew were nice too like it's very
is it too much well I know the
pornography is too much I can't even
like I remember if you wanted to see
some crotch we had a kid in our class
who would drew the best vagina and dude
he was coming for three years that's all
he did people were like dude I need a
c-1 you know and he would he would H up
a great one you know and he had all
different kinds he had different
ethnicities you could hit him up you
know I remember sneaking up riding my
bike over to his house at 8:00 p.m. one
night to get us just a quick sketch of
some puss you know and that was how we
got it you know if you didn't have a an
access to some good nudie magazines and
then my buddy's dad used to keep nudie
magazines tit literature under his sink
and I would bike over there four or five
miles to go see that to take a dump
yeah my thing we would steal my friend's
dad's porno yeah that DHS tape hidden
what he thought was hidden under his TV
but any night that they were out of town
we're all going assess house we're
checking out that porno dude I remember
I used to babysit
some kids right and one weekend when the
whole family was out of town I broke
into their house to watch pornography
that the parents had so it's just yeah
like when you have these young people
and it's it was just different back then
because now if you had your cell phone I
can't how you would even leave school or
leave the house how you would even make
it out of the door without masturbating
I cannot fathom let's hear a little more
like that when you were younger dude if
you have any comments or thoughts on on
that whole situation in that scenario
but at any rate man thank you for thanks
for listening to the people of our
nation it's a weird state of affairs
that we're all in and I'm excited to
continue to listen your podcast and
catch nothing well I appreciate that may
not even cut you off there but uh but I
appreciate the the nice words yeah you
know and Ari and I were just talking
about that what what you know what I
mean Ari would you serve what would he
be how would your childhood honestly
have been different if you had access to
the sexual library of pornography and
material that's out there now back then
I mean dude forget how my childhood
would be different my adult life is
different because of the access to
pornography I masturbate way more than
I'm sure I would without it so yeah if I
was a kid with even more horny whatever
whatever the word is all those hormones
raging inside me full dick I had full
dick back yeah it would I think it would
it could have been a problem so I think
maybe they have to tackle that in sex ed
maybe that's a whole new chapter that
they didn't teach us in our sex ed we
just learned the body parts maybe now
they have to teach you responsible
masturbation techniques it's kind of
like those dare programs for drugs they
need to make something like that for
porno and sex
yeah dare to keep kids off of pornhub
yeah I know I think that's probably a
real thing they probably that's
something that has to be talked about
more than it used to because it's so
more so much more accessible to kids
yeah yeah it was you know the first time
I saw some nudie magazines we were
burying
some dead animals and we found some and
then another time some kid who ended up
setting my hair on fire this I think I
think he was Polynesian I go back but
yeah thank you yeah this I think this
one kid and he slammed me up against a
tree outside in the rain and he had a
picture of some cooter in his pocket you
know of some fresh cooter out of a
magazine and he said you know what that
is boy that's cooter boy and then he
just beat me him and his friends just
beat me and I was like what the [ __ ] is
going on yeah and he gave me a lot of
weird feelings about looking at you know
looking at actual magazine sex but yeah
I can't I cannot fathom these kids I
can't fathom it would just be like it
would be like growing up in Colombia
that's what I like I would get an eight
ball for my 10th birthday and I would
never see the light of day again you
know I just so I don't know but yeah but
then when I look back on it I remember
feeling a girl's titty through a barbed
wire fence one time and that just took
me to another level I felt like I was
sitting I couldn't even feel my legs
that's how good that titty felt you know
one girl I remember feeling her chest at
the movies she have any titties dude she
just had just nipples that were a little
bit different than mine but you still
loved it oh yeah I was so erect dude I
don't even know I couldn't even feel any
part of my body except for my penis all
my nerves ran into my penis and just
felt like they just started [ __ ] each
other at the end of my skin they
probably were it was just you know those
hormones are so powerful but I
appreciate you calling in and asking
about school yeah and it's interesting
it's interesting to think about what's
going on you know and you were on that
dirty bus ride and you know you're out
there just filling your hands with that
sweet cheese you know and uh and just I
do love the espionage of the of the of
the of the chaperone just lurking around
and here you are just crotch and down
yeah you imagine getting caught at 13
doing that in the bus yeah I would be
uncomfortable and you'd be a hero
because true oh you would be a legend
all right let's take another caller here
here we go hey so you got a question for
you but games down here and pour it on
our fifth day without power games
talking about different games onward and
have been playing a lot of card games
with the old lady now when I was a kid
we didn't have internet or cable
television for that matter and we had to
come up with our own games to keep us
occupied we used to we used to play you
know you got your kicked the bucket
you got your well we used to call it
horse it was just like a poor man's
horse where you just kind of pick up
rocks and try and hit stuff that sounds
like that sounds real Middle Eastern but
onward and of course you got freeze tag
and spotlight in spotlight if you
haven't heard of spotlight it's
basically freeze tag at night where you
got a flashlight my buddy Darius he did
he'd win that one all the time my
question is what kind of games did y'all
play down in Louisiana as a kid before
you know before all this internet stuff
well one in my in my town I've talked
about this before is gay chicken where
you and your buddy or you and a fella
would hold on each other's wiener and it
sounds perverse but it's not and the
first person who let go was gay so you
were basically but if you got an
erection you were also gay you know and
this is a time when you know people be
like oh you're gay as if it was a bat
you know it was a wrong thing or
something that's how you lost you know
so yeah I remember doing that and I
wouldn't you know play it as an adult
unless it was for charity now but I
remember at the time holding on you know
getting to know another man quickly and
you know and it's weird because you're
hoping they get a wreck so they lose and
and you'll stay in there and the later
rounds you start slapping each other too
interesting yeah and then when you let
go it's a little bit more of like a
rodeo how old were you going on 11 12 13
you got to be old enough to get it
wrecked I guess you got to remember who
got excited to play that game the most
that person is probably yeah that's a
good point the gay probably it was a few
of the older boys yeah yeah yeah this
one kid named Shawn dude s actually SH
hmm
you were
molested actually no man no no these
were these were everybody was under the
age of 18 that played okay this one kids
shum and this one boy named inch cut man
he didn't even have any legs
going back to you know we're talking
about people that are missing things and
stuff but this boy didn't have any legs
and he still had a hell of a dick on him
and something yeah and you had to kind
of sit down there with him to play or
his brother would hold him up and he
would play but but that was a time when
you know everything wasn't so crazy back
then you know people were I guess there
was a lot of sexual weird stuff you know
when you're at those young ages you just
experiment yeah you know I remember one
time walking in on a couple of younger
family members of mine and they were you
know putting their thumbs in each others
butts he's two boys you know and they
weren't you know they're both in healthy
adult relationships now it was just kids
yeah some things you just kind of block
out yeah it's just kids doing stuff yeah
you know I remain there was just a time
when people were doing different things
when they were younger but different
games we playing Louise here I remember
gay chicken we had this game called
banshee where you would put a pillowcase
or something over somebody's head and
then they would run around and try to
catch people and it was really
impossible for him to catch anybody but
uh but it was brave as [ __ ] they trying
to catch people run full steam we're
just in the in a hot bag pretty
mesmerizing so I guess that was that we
had the game where you had cut a knot
you fill your mouth for sugar and try to
knock the sugar out of each other's
mouth what else did we play not to think
about this and get back to you man
thinking about some of the games that we
play you know we we play those games at
night you know hide-and-go-seek at night
we'd get on the CB radio and see if we
could get perverts to come over and then
this dude would always beat them up this
older dude there's a lot of truckers
would drive off the interstate that were
really perverts alright let's get into
another one here here we go I was Josh
Colin again from Charlotte thanks for
calling Josh Colin C we should go about
having a girlfriend had that Super
Soaker downstairs but uh
the podcast man but I was thinking you
talk about having some Jess come on soon
what about how long this - come on dude
give a shout I'll call out on Monday to
chit chat with the legend but anyway
Amanda stirrer thought also elaborate on
that shirt you had on this past Monday
dude looks like a buffet for Timon and
Pumba the Lion King eternity
oh that was my bug cert man I went
shopping and got me a bug sir just got a
lot of bugs on it cuz sometimes I feel
like I'm infested with different things
and so I felt like that shirt kind of
documented that but it's I'm glad that
you called actually back because I had a
psychologist that called in who had some
answers to some of your questions about
your girlfriend was spraying out you had
the girlfriend that had that magical
crotch you know that um that took
everlasting down there you know and
she's just you know squirter yeah she
was really just doing that you know she
was a real fireman if you will you know
she was down there killing heat with
that um with some sweet wine you know
some making crotch wine and the gift
yeah they say it's a gift man in some
places it's illegal to there's a some
country it Saudi Arabia maybe I can
imagine it being illegal there I think
it's in Africa but I know that but I
know she had some thoughts for you
someone put you guys on a mashup this
week and I'll put that out on YouTube
where you can get some of our thoughts
but yeah well look I'm taking some of
the guidance right now by having orient
and by having a residency here with a
sidekick so maybe that maybe as a
sidekick I can work on getting a live
caller in here and I'll screen the call
because you know that's something that
Theo shouldn't have to do just because
it's a lot of work the screening calls
because you you add calling to the mix
then you're adding people calling in and
just masturbating over the phone yeah
and you're getting calls like that and
you have to weed those out and just get
to the responsible young folks like
yourself yeah and I've had some of that
I've had people call in and leave
voicemails of them just you know
touching themselves and doing different
stuff like yeah so we don't 100% want
that let's take another call man let's
take another call here all right we're
really cruising through some yeah yeah
CEO what's up you know glitter biscuit
I'll take that one
is Josh I'm calling from the rural
Midwest thank you for calling you made a
comment on a previous podcast about how
in the future the handicapped people
would be in power they would hold the
power and that they would be the ruling
class yes I did know I know you probably
just saying that haphazardly but I think
there's some prophetic validity to it
because I think you're a prophet I think
your comedic prophet and I think I think
that there's something to that statement
that's terrifying but I think it might
be true I was wondering if you maybe
could expound upon that for us I will
man I appreciate you calling and
remembering and asking about that thank
you I do believe that everything evens
out you know so if you got like you know
I'm talking about my buddy who lost an
arm right in the beginning next life
biggest dick ever you know that guy's
coming with a dick that will [ __ ] you
know they could probably bunt a baseball
you know or a dicta can thumb wrestle
you know and I believe it all evens out
I don't believe I mean I believe you
might go to a heaven or to a higher
place or to a Hell where you got a
battle I just believe that it all evens
out you know if you uh if you were a
slave to work in this life then the next
life you get to be a slave to you know
more joy and spending time with people
that you love you know I just think that
everything seems to even out and in the
future I could see you know people that
are able-bodied and people that are you
know seem normal to us now as being you
know the weaker of the species you know
I could see in the future we wake up in
a realm where there's mentally
handicapped people with swords and
riding on these you know gladiator bikes
and shooting them you know rubber
bullets at people and you know starting
little fun Wars and [ __ ] you know and
they're the rulers and we all have to be
down here and you know sleeping wet
sleep under wet blankets and eat
butter only and you think that's not fun
but you think that is fun but eating
peanut butter is hard after the first
couple bites and so I just think it all
evens out man and I think we're gonna
you know we can't see it all so clearly
now but if we think of it a little bit
more that way then it just takes a
little bit of the pressure off you know
and you see a handicapped dude next time
some guy who's you know you sometimes
you see that one guy who's just like
jiangha and down the street you know
he's barely got it together and he's
fighting for every step and next time
that dude is doing jiu-jitsu and that
dude is you know cash and checks and
snapping necks and eating air [ __ ] and
living the dream you know when playing
guitars and doing whatever he wants to
do I feel like I just feel like it has
to be and so you know I think it just
helps me to keep things in perspective
sometimes you know you see somebody who
thinks that they have it all now and but
then next time they realize you know or
we all realize what you know the other
side of the coin is like what do you
think are you you think you know I never
really thought about it till right now
but I think there's definitely a lot of
truth to what you're spitting out and I
think especially in today's age with the
second life in this digital world that
we're making in in 3d and those glasses
the Google Goggles you could be anything
you want to be now if it's not in this
world maybe the digital world so you're
gonna see it's a good point um you know
our our able body is like you said it's
not gonna matter as much yeah I mean it
matters right now cuz we're walking
around we need them we need them but but
I'd say potentially even in our
lifetimes sooner than you think you're
not gonna need it you could do basically
everything just sitting in your chair at
home laying in bed whatever so it's not
gonna matter if you're disabled then
these disabled people may even
capitalize on this and take advantage of
it because well we're going to go out
and want to live our lives they don't
need to it they could just work at home
and do their thing and take over the
world yeah when you imagine when you
really start to imagine that's dude
that's a great point because that helps
me think all right that when you start
to think like a say somebody that have
autism you know but they get to build
this Sims world or something you know
and then you we have our house in The
Sims universe or in this digital
universe where we invite people over and
it's like a regular house you know but
they create some masterpiece because
they are able to you know tap into other
realms and they're able to you know just
they're just able to think differently
than we are yeah I mean they got the
they got the you know they got the Lords
yeast in their brain and they're able to
really just get to levels that we're not
able to get to and so when when when we
get to a place technologically or physio
technologically where we can expound
upon those people's brains and those
people's imaginations man who knows what
are you gonna crack into and and maybe
that yeah maybe that's going to be part
of you know maybe it won't even be like
leaving this earth and going to
somewhere else maybe it'll be right here
but yeah I think that the you know the
people that have experienced the
toughest you know it won't always be
that way
I just think it all evens out and it and
when you see you know sometimes you go
to like to back to high school reunions
and somebody who you know was had
something before they don't have it now
yeah and we when you didn't have pride
before you didn't have self-esteem or
you have you know suffered from
self-loathing a lot but now you you're
not suffering that anymore and it's
interesting that that if you get to live
long enough you kind of get to see
everything go full circle a little bit
you know you kind of get to see you kind
of get to see it all you kind of get to
see what it was all about so yeah I love
that question I love that thought man
and I love the fact that one day you
know people with Down's syndrome will be
John Snow yeah they'll be allowed to
join the military I said well I'm joined
I'm joining the military yeah and let
him hug the [ __ ] out of people dude
because I've always had an idea that if
you put a Down syndrome fellow every
every drug deal in corner in America
where people's dealing drugs that the
game will change out there you know
because it's hard to deal drugs when
somebody's giving you a hug
you know it's hard to want to get all
coked up when somebody's just hugging
you from behind really hard or making
you feel loved I've always believed a
lot of that all right I want to get to a
question from one of our patreon highest
level supporters here this is William
Morris asking what's the most
embarrassing moment of your life respect
the oh love the show the most
embarrassing moment of my life
when I was in grade school
they had this thing called campus life
and it was where kids would go spend
time and it was religious based but it
was just like a fun night for kids to go
do things together like on a Wednesday
night
so in junior high gave you a place to
meet up and you would do some like fun
games and just a place to see kids at
night because you were just used to
seeing them during the daytime so we
went into the campus life meeting one
night and they had me and a pretty girl
we were playing a game and the game was
to eat three bananas and you had to be
blindfolded while you was eating the
bananas so eating bananas in the dark
and I've never been a gay man you know
or I've never been a blind monkey but I
can imagine that both of those types of
people have had similar experiences to
this and so they blindfolded you and
they blindfolded while they blindfolded
me and they blindfolded the young lady
and I was like nervous because I didn't
really do a lot of stuff with pretty
girls so even just being close to this
pretty girl it was like you know
everybody was looking at me and her and
the same time and I was just like oh and
I think I was only in seventh grade and
some of the other kids were in eighth
and ninth grade so you know there was
those levels of nerves as well the older
kids and you know they know more and
they're smarter and cooler and blah blah
well they blindfold us and we have to
eat the bananas as fast as we can
so I start eating and I've always
enjoyed fruits you know my whole life
when I think back on my life I've always
really enjoyed a good fruit I used to
enjoy watching my brother eat oranges my
brother used to eat a lot of oranges he
would eat he'd get him a little sack of
oranges and just eat him sometimes and I
would enjoy just even watching him eat
them because we didn't do a lot of
things together as a family that were
peaceful most of the times we would
fight so I found a lot of joy just
watching my brother you know tap into
them vitamin C balls well so here I am
I'm gumming down these bananas these
bananas and I get through all three a
swallow people are cheering and laughing
and everybody and I take off my
blindfold and everybody else was gone
everybody else wasn't playing the game
that's what I mean the girl wasn't
playing the game the pretty girl she was
the second we started they kind of
tapped her on the shoulder and quietly
told her to just go back over with
everybody else who was watching so I had
been eatin three bananas in front of
everybody all my peers by myself as fast
as I could and I had acne and I had
suddenly all the things that were wrong
with me were the only things that I
could think about you know I just felt
you know I had acne and I had big ears
and I you know everything was wrong with
me my pants were too tight and they
tapered at the at the bottoms and looked
kind of maybe like a woman's pants and
just and I just felt horrible uh I you
know I played it off that it was funny
you know the joke was just that I don't
even know what the joke was the joke was
that you know everybody got to watch me
bananas and then I was okay you know it
was just silly and it was nobody else
thought anything of it but man I felt I
felt man I was already so insecure and I
guess I just felt even more insecure and
that was probably the most embarrassing
moment of my life you know that I
remember as a child I'm sure there were
but that was one that really just grew
out of my balls like a dam I mean just
like a dam just like a dam white hair
you know I remember when I was young the
first hair I ever got that grew out of
my ball bag was white and I remember
just being so nervous and and my daddy
was so old you know my daddy was you
know 83 or 82 when I got up when I got
some hair on my balls so I just figured
it was the end of his genetics or the
you know whatever his genetics it was a
little bit of that had kind of you know
dribbled down into my ball bag and uh
and I was just so you know I just that's
how I felt I guess I felt like this lone
white hair and I felt like a lone white
ball hair just full of potassium and
that's all that's all the patreon
questions that we have so I think we're
gonna wrap up - I got to go over to the
comments I got to go to the Comedy Store
into a set already I appreciate it man I
appreciate you letting me be here and
helping you out hopefully I'm helping
you and and hopefully this podcast grows
to be bigger and better than it
each episode bigger and better thanks
man yeah and I want to thank you guys
for tuning in I want to thank you guys
for sticking with you with the new
sidekick you know we're gonna try it
give it a residency for a little bit see
how we feel you know you can send me
comments you can send me messages you
can let me know what you think it might
take a little bit we're just gonna give
it a run you know I got to be open to
trying new things even if sometimes they
feel uncomfortable tonight honestly are
he's gone but you know I felt a little
awkward you know I felt excited to spend
time with my buddy but also you know
just nervous I'm used to this being my
space and my place and our place where
we sit and chat about things and share
stuff so you know it was some new
feelings but but I was happy to you know
try it out with you guys and and see
where we go
so we'll keep you know
I think we'll try it again and we'll see
how it goes but I want to thank you guys
for being with us this week I want to
thank everybody that called in some
great callers and hit the hotline nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three I think I'm going to be able to
produce the episode a little bit more
next week so try to get maybe more of a
theme you know I'm doing what I can and
I appreciate you guys being supportive
thank you to all the patreon doors thank
you to anyone who's listening to the
podcast subscribe to it if you're
watching on youtube or watching on on on
on iTunes just hit that subscription you
know every little bit helps let's build
the following and and keep hitting me up
with constructive criticism thank you
guys for being a part of my weekend
thank everybody for Cle in Cleveland
that came out a lot of beautiful friends
my friend Carla came through this young
lady named Renee came out to the show
and she just found out that her family
that her father who had passed away
wasn't her real father and that she had
this whole new step family that she
never knew about and it was her birthday
and they all came out to the comedy show
in Cleveland so here she is with this
whole new family and they're all sitting
there in the audience laughing together
and it was you know it's cool because
that's something that they you know
we'll be able to have as they move
forward just laughing about hamsters or
laughing about whatever so I just felt
awesome to be a part of that and I
appreciate you guys being here with me I
really do
already my weeks great just because you
guys showed up and give me some your
constructive criticism let's move onward
together let's listen to my man
Spencer Jacob growl on the way out if he
need me hit me up on the hotline or
email me Theo von at mac.com
ma c-calm I'll talk to you guys soon
[Music]
cellophane is
we all die
celebrate dog day
seven me Oh
be good yourselves
[Music]
let's
while we all die